[Music]
for all the episodes of a bit of
optimism
i've talked to people i know or people
whose work i'm familiar with
andy grammer is the exception i think i
might be getting old because
i have to admit i didn't know his work a
mutual friend of ours said we had to
meet and that we would get along
i trust my friend and so i invited andy
to join me
on the podcast and my friend was right
andy is wonderful and we got along so
well
he's such an amazing optimist but he
comes at optimism from a completely
different angle his starts with pain
and i found it absolutely fascinating
this
isn't a bit of optimism this is a lot of
optimism
so i have to ask what was the reason you
wanted to do this
well you know i'm a super optimist
and i run around the country and sing
songs and i've had songs on the radio
and it's
a big piece of my life also i'm just
like a huge fan of you
i'm a really big fan of all of your
books
and so i'm like oh man i gotta talk to
that guy because i think we have a lot
of similar
thoughts on life and how to bring an
optimism that isn't just airy fairy
that's like oh everything's good because
it's good i like to talk about a
grounded optimism
and sing about it and i think that's
similar to what you're about how do you
define optimism
to me i think optimism is
the genuine belief that
whatever happens to you makes you better
if you truly believe that anything
good that happens to you makes you
better and then the bad stuff is there
to make you better
i think you were inherently an optimist
in like a true way
that's grounded tell me more about that
i had a song
come out called wish you pain which was
a little bit tough to pitch to radio but
we tried
it was like an aggressive title and for
my meet and greet
we had everybody in a circle i'd start
and i'd say
listen i lost my mom when i was 25
it was the worst thing that had ever
happened to me it broke me down to a
million pieces
and it gave me an empathy for the world
that i would never have
i'm a sunny happy person and i need to
get hit really hard to even be able to
see how other people will be going
through what they're going through
so i'd start my meet and greet that way
and i would say that's my deepest thing
and now i'm telling you from there
this is what i got i dare everyone in
this room to step forward and share
their deepest pain
and what they got from it and it was
wild i did it 40 cities
and there were about 100 people in each
group and people did not hold back it
wasn't like
oh i didn't get into college i didn't
want to it's like my infant died
and for two years we were in the dark
and we couldn't get out
and then they stood in power and said
and now when another infant dies at the
hospital they call us
and we're like the superheroes that come
in to console people and it's the most
meaningful work we've ever done
and so i saw heavy things like that
happen over and over and over and over
again
and you start to train yourself to see
life that way and i think that
that is an optimism that i can get
behind there's post-traumatic stress
and there's the less talked about
post-traumatic growth
oh totally and it's victor frankl stuff
right
yeah like we cannot control the
circumstances around us all we can
control is our reaction or our attitude
and so my great-aunt lived through the
holocaust
and she actually had her first child
on the train on the way to the
concentration camp holy [ __ ]
and she would tell me that you came out
of that
one of two ways you came out of it
broken or you came out of it stronger
that was it she came out of it stronger
her husband came out of it broken
and she said that's what made us such a
great pair such a great couple which is
i got to be there for him
and he was there for me and we have this
perfect marriage because
we are the opposite wow my optimism
is slightly different than yours you ask
people what's your greatest pain
and i asked people when did you have
love
and so i'll ask you my question it can
be career
oriented or not but tell me something
you've done in your life that you
absolutely loved being a part of
i'm always terrified of being cheesy but
the answer that comes to my head
is just being of service no but tell me
something specific
so the way that i feel like i'm the most
of service is when i'm able to
either craft a little ball of love or
meaning
in a three-minute song that then goes to
strangers and i can
in comment sections or whatever feel the
reverberation of it blowing up inside
them
or at a show where you're like all
singing together there's something about
singing together that is just so
unifying
in an unbelievable way so those are
things you've done regularly
i want one specific experience you've
had
and that if everything you did was like
this one thing
you literally would be the happiest
person alive made a video for a song
called fresh eyes which is about seeing
people differently
and we spent the music video budget on
going down to skid row and giving
makeovers to homeless people
and at the end of the day we all hung
out the feeling that you get from that
is
just unbelievable the human connection
of it is like holy [ __ ]
why are we not just doing this every day
but you've done nice things for people
all the time you told me about your
circles
what specifically was it about going
down to skid row and giving them
makeovers
that stands out that it's the reason
you're telling me about it
it goes back to this idea of being a
service
someone needs service and when you give
it to them
the bigger the love explosion so there
was like holy [ __ ] everybody needs this
and we were able to provide it
it was amazing okay tell me an early
specific happy childhood memory
a very specific happy childhood memory
was that
i loved anything impressive like
magic and i got into juggling and my mom
just heard that i like juggling and then
one day i woke up and there was
handmade juggling pins outside my door
and then i went out in the yard and i
tried to learn how to do it for hours
and hours
i remember loving that that's like a
happy memory and you've had lots of
happy things in your life
any idea as to why that memory stands
out your mom gave you plenty of gifts
what was it about this one that stands
out
it was that someone was watching me
closely enough
and then had my back in a really
thoughtful way
that led me to feel like i got your back
in whatever you do and you don't even
have to ask for it i'm just here
pushing you forward so do you know
what's so fascinating about those two
stories you told me
what the exact same story your mother
heard something that you wanted you
didn't even know that she knew
and she showed up and gave you this
thing and it made you feel seen and it
made you feel heard
and it was transformative in your life
because she gave you this gesture that
something that
opened you up what did you do in skid
row you understood that
these are people who are in transition
something has happened to them in their
lives and they're in transition
and they want to be seen and they want
to be heard and they want to be
beautiful again
and you showed up and you ostensibly
gave them juggling pins
sure you gave them something bespoked
and handmade
because you made the point to say that
they were handmade you pointed out that
detail
you did something that wasn't generic
you didn't give one of something to
everybody you gave something bespoke to
each one of them
it's the same thing so for me that's
where your why exists
you're why you go through life to give
people something
that they need that allows them to feel
seen and heard and it is because of that
thing that they're able to make the
transformation they need to make or find
the joy they need to find
and you know what's so crazy i don't
know if you found this with talking
different people's why's
when you're telling me about my why i'm
like isn't that everyone's why
everybody says that everybody says that
because it's so innate in who you are it
is who you are it is the reason you get
out of bed every morning is what
inspires you what it is what
underlies all of your work that it's so
obvious to you when it's pointed out to
you like yeah of course that's
everything that brings me joy but
everybody's why is completely different
and everybody thinks their why is the
same as everybody because they imagine
that everybody's living
or should live the same life that they
live and i'm here to tell you they don't
they don't and i'm sure you've thought
about it what's what is your why
to inspire people to do the things that
inspire them so that each of us can
change our world for the better
it's to give something special to
someone that they feel seen and heard so
that they can go through a
transformation that they need to go
through
yeah that's why you show up in the world
and what's so interesting is
your circles do that what you're doing
you give people something bespoked which
is you give them this experience you
want them to tell their experience
it's not a generic thing and you make
them feel seen and heard you give them
the space
and it is that moment that critical
piece that they can now
just like with your juggling pins just
like on skid row that this is the thing
that now gives them
the ability permission to go on and make
the transformation they need to make
yeah we would take it even further in
the show we'd pick someone out of the
crowd
and they would come up and i would
interview them on stage in front of
everyone
and ask them to share and then me and my
band would try to write a song on the
spot
and it was awesome you mean give them
something bespoked and handmade just for
them
you don't say yeah don't say andy yeah
don't say
but what i was interesting is that just
watching that happen
if you're an audience member you're also
getting something handmade of course
and very specific you're a part of the
night that's very unique and special
it almost gives you permission to look
at what yours is it was really really
cool
this is the magic of oxytocin oxytocin
is this magical chemical in our body
that is responsible for why we feel love
for each other a friendship with each
other why we feel kinship and loyalty
and
all of those irrational things when
women give birth
there's a huge surge of oxytocin in
their bodies at that moment
and this is what is responsible for the
mother child bond
yeah and the magical thing about
oxytocin is we get it
when we do something nice for someone
with no expectation of anything in
return so you do something nice
all these things that you're doing make
you feel good isn't this the secret the
secret to happiness is what you just
said i think
and it feels good when somebody does
something nice for us when your mom gave
you the pins when you went to skid row
when you wrote the song for the people
they get overwhelmed with emotion
because it feels nice when somebody does
something for us with no expectation of
anything in return but the best part
about oxytocin in my opinion
is that witnessing an act of kindness or
generosity releases
oxytocin in our bodies and the more
oxytocin you have in your body
the more generous you actually become in
other words you
making a bespoke song for somebody only
one person
on the stage and the thousands of people
in the audience watching
not only do they feel good because of
this act of intense kindness and
generosity
but everybody in your audience is more
likely to do something nice for someone
or be a little kinder to someone
because you filled them with oxytocin
before they left the arena
oxytocin is the original viral it's the
kindness virus
yes and this is what's so magical you're
not just showing up to sing songs and
people who enjoy the songs
show up but there's a purpose and cause
underlying
and i would even go so far as to say
that there are people who are showing up
to your concerts
who may think your music is fine
but what they love because a friend
dragged them to one of your concerts
yeah like he's fine i guess i'll go with
you you know and the experience
of the concert of what you do for people
and how you make them feel which goes
way beyond the music
is the reason they come back for more
and more and more and the music and you
now become the symbol
of the thing that they now believe in
which is these random acts of kindness
and generosity
at some points in my life i'm like more
apt to just play with it
than others and i don't know why but
right now this week
just did this morning got my coffee and
i look at the guy like can you just pay
for the car behind me
the starbucks employee and then i tell
them
also can you tell them something sweet
and it's such a simple idea but it sets
up my whole day
fantastic so i told him today i was like
i need you to look
her in the eye whoever she is because i
oh i could kind of tell as a lady
and you look in the eye and just say i
love you and then say that your coffee
is paid for
and then i leave and i feel like a rush
of something it's unbelievable it's
oxytocin
this is a hack on life to do little
things for other people
so here's the impact this is what i love
about these things they come big and
small
clearly writing a song for someone on
the spot is a big thing although it
probably doesn't feel that way for you
let's be honest it definitely does for
them and it definitely does for
everybody in the audience
but what i love about this thing is it's
the ripple which is
not only did you feel good because you
did something nice for someone the
person on the receiving end of the
coffee and the compliment
amazing the person who you asked to be
complicit
in your little scheme the barista
that person feels amazing even though
yeah
they're just in the transaction and by
the way every single one of those people
told the story of what happened today
the barista told
their colleagues the person buying the
coffee told whoever they were meeting up
with right afterwards
you're telling me now i'm getting
goosebumps
i'm feeling good we're telling the story
on a podcast
and this is how it ripples this is how
goodness happens
and i think there's something about
going on offense that a lot of people
will wait for it
or they just won't be involved in the
game of it and it can be like a fun
thing that you just like
start to see and are looking for at all
times is how do i
create this feeling that feels so good
by going on offense and doing something
nice for somebody else
and oxytocin the more you do it the more
you want it so it actually makes us more
and more generous
it's mother nature's desperate attempt
to try to get us to look after each
other is what it is
and so when you get in this rut of being
selfish
or self-involved or it's all about me
my success me me me all our
relationships become transactional
what can this person do for me totally
it actually hurts your health i mean the
more oxytocin you have in your body
people who are happy actually live
longer they have lower rates of cancer
diabetes and heart disease
and so oxytocin is actually a stress
killer
it actually reduces the cortisol on our
body which is the feeling of stress
and so not only is this good for the
human race it's it's actually a
healthier way to live
and this is why you and i are enjoying
talking because we're living in a world
right now
that has unfortunately seemingly become
more and more selfish more and more
short term
we've seen it in business we've seen it
in politics everything is about
me first how can i win how can i get
something out of this
short-term horizons we don't plan for
the future anymore we don't consider
each other
yeah and it actually makes us unhealthy
and unhappy yeah and to turn it around
does not require
getting custom-made juggling pins or
knowing how to write a song for somebody
what to turn it around
like one baby step in the right
direction is to buy a coffee for
somebody that didn't
expect it buy someone else's coffee i'm
also fascinated by
the barriers to this like i always talk
about
a rhythm when i try to do service for
someone else
and the rhythm of for me is always that
i have an idea
to do something nice for someone and
that's step one step two
is it's hard to define it but something
shows up that goes like don't do that
that i have to break through every time
what the hell is that
i've done like a lot of things where for
my birthday we'll make sandwiches and
we'll collect
clothes we'll bring it down to skid row
and somewhere on the drive down to skid
row
i start to doubt is this a good idea
which is ludicrous so the act for me of
being of service usually comes with
pushing through something as well which
i'm interested to hear your thoughts on
that's really interesting because i
assume we all have that i mean i
definitely have that too and i guess
too many people listen to that little
voice and hold it back
yeah but we don't even know what we're
stopping for i try to define it it's
just that
i'm afraid to look stupid or i'm afraid
that it won't go right
yeah i think that's all it is you said
it before like your biggest fear is
being cheesy
yeah some of the things that we think to
do for somebody
is sometimes cheesy paying someone a
compliment
it just happened to me this morning i
woke up this morning checking my emails
and
scrolling through the text that had come
from the east coast
and i wrote to one friend typed her name
and wrote your magic
and she'd sent me something i didn't
know she sent me she goes oh did it
arrive i said
nope she goes wait you just said this to
me
i'm like yep and she's like that's made
my day
but think about how so many people think
to do something like that
to a friend like a thought popped into
your head of that friend you're like oh
i like that person and don't act upon it
yeah it happens all the time every day
you think of somebody like oh that's
nice i like them
and just to go the one step further to
send a text like i just want you to know
i like you
that's it now it makes me think of like
being in shape
being in like happy shape it's like
getting to a place where
the little things won't stop you and you
just plow through
i think that's a great analogy i think
it is a little light exercise you know
if you work the muscle you get stronger
and if you do these things frequently
they actually become super easy and that
little voice either gets diminished or
goes away yeah
i'm pretty open about having lost my mom
and sing about it a lot and
i had this crazy story where i was
playing a show in
boston i'm sitting at my table having
breakfast
and these four women come in that remind
me of my mother
they're about the same age and i'm like
you know it's a bummer i never get to
buy
my mom breakfast that's like that'd be
really cool to take her out for
breakfast
and so i have this thought of i should
buy them breakfast
and then like i said it always shows up
i think have a good idea and then the
negative definitely don't do that that's
the dumbest idea ever starts attacking
my brain
like what you're gonna seem like a big
shot you're gonna tell them you're
playing tonight you wanna like
look really cool and i'm sitting there
and i have this real now intense sense
like you should do this thing that you
thought of
i'm sweating but by myself eating eggs
very confused
like why this is not a thing that's
normal for me i'm very very like oh my
god
so then i finally get into it i step up
i walk over to these four ladies and i
say listen
i don't want to bother you i lost my mom
about
10 years ago and you all for some reason
reminded me of her
would you allow me to buy your breakfast
and the one on the far left
immediately starts crying she stands up
and says i just lost my son who's about
your age
and now i'm hugging crying with a
stranger just like
stranger is now my family member we're
crying and we're loving each other these
little things
there's a barrier to break through but
then your life gets like crazy rich
it's so interesting there's like this
little thing of like do nice things
just do it i love the fact that it's not
just the recognition of the thing
but then there's a thought that comes
after which is what you have that
i don't think everybody has i think a
lot of people would sit at breakfast and
look at a table and say ah
they remind me of my mom and then that
thought would stop
there'd be a little warmth but your
inclination is to go
how do i do something nice for them just
in gratitude for this nice feeling
they've given me
yes it's like you want to pay back the
generosity of them being
yes i think that is actually not as
normal as you like to think
um i think you and i both would like it
to be normal yes
the thing that i also find really
interesting is for you pain is really
the starting point
yeah because that to me makes optimism
foolproof sometimes that word optimism
gets like yeah but you're not living in
the real world you know
us here in the real world we're going
through it and you're just happy over
there
there's this quote that i wrote that
song we should paint about
the more difficulties one sees in the
world the more perfect one becomes the
more you plow and dig the ground the
more fertile it becomes
the more you cut the branches of the
tree the higher and stronger it grows
this is a quote that i was taught with
growing up
and so you start to see struggle as as a
piece of the whole puzzle it's like a
part of it
not not something that just sucks it's
like the gym we go to the gym we work
out
everybody agrees but it's harder to see
that in life
when your mom does i like extreme
examples because the lessons are easier
to see
you realize the opportunity for growth
after pain
if you trip on the sidewalk you don't
see it so easily
yeah but when your mother dies it's a
lot easier to see just because it's so
extreme
yeah it's extreme and then you can take
that into when you trip on the sidewalk
right
i think that's a must it's a muscle too
right and so and so when you ask people
to relive their most difficult moments
when you do your circles i understand
that you're allowing them to learn the
lesson from the extreme
and that lesson can then translate and
see it in everybody else
that's what's cool too i often share
the story of alcoholics anonymous
alcoholics anonymous
is a 12-step program and many people
know the first step
and to admit you have a problem yeah and
people who've gone through alcoholics
anonymous
can tell you that if you master all 11
steps but not the 12th
the odds are higher that you'll succumb
to the disease
but if you master the 12 steps the odds
significantly increase that you will
beat the disease
the 12th step is to help another
alcoholic the 12th step is service
yeah i get this question all the time i
feel like i've lost my purpose and i
don't know what i want to do in life
and i'm struggling and i'm stuck what do
i do and i say oh yeah okay
find somebody else who doesn't feel like
they have any sense of purpose that
they're struggling stuck and don't know
what they do go help them go help them
and you will find everything you're
looking for but you have to help them
genuinely you can't help them in order
to help yourself
you have to help them because you
actually want to help them because you
may not get what you're looking for
this time yes you have to do it again
from like a music perspective service to
me
it's very clear that when you're playing
music
you can see who's doing the service
especially when you get started and
you're terrible
you can tell that your family is giving
you their attention
they're doing you the service i like
listening to you play
and i was a street performer for four
years and i could watch
people's faces while i was playing and
they'd be like you're doing me the
service at this point
and just keep working working trying to
get better trying to get better trying
to get better and then there's this
shift that occurs
where it's like oh now i am actually
doing you the service oh my god
this is amazing and that's when things
start to move and that's when you feel
better
and seeing everything from that
perspective what is a hit song it's that
it hits someone's ears and they're like
oh
you're giving me something this is dope
you're like they're actually being of
service to me
i have to ask how does one go from
performing on the streets of santa
monica to
now having a real music career
the word that comes up for me is just
persistence just like not giving up
and then i guess you know goes back to
your thing of like having a good enough
why to be persistent probably
but yeah i kept going out kept writing
songs
slowly figuring out what is actually of
service to people what is my gift how do
i share it
and showing up every day and i had been
performing
all day and hadn't gotten one dollar not
one person had put anything in my case
and it's a whole thing to get out there
you're like pack up your mom's minivan
it takes like 40 minutes to get out
there you have to get out there early to
wait for a spot
in santa monica it's like a real schlep
and to set everything up and you gotta
move every two hours
and i'd moved like three times and i'd
been playing and no one stopped
for about 11 hours of playing music to
the world just being ignored for about
11 hours
and i put my stuff down getting ready to
pack up
and i looked up at the sky and i said uh
they thought i was crazy there's a lot
of people that are crazy out there so
they blended perfectly in
and i look at this guy said your move
like i'm
never leaving so if you want me to just
be here
in 20 years sing to people walking by
i'm down for that i just need you to
know
that i will still be here and i'm never
leaving so
you might as well just give in because
i'm gonna keep going
and then i went home and wrote this song
like i picked me up to myself
called keep your head up and that's the
one that took off that's amazing
andy grammer you're an absolute joy to
talk to so inspiring
you must feel similar like i'm sure a
lot of people come up and tell you
what i get sometimes from songs which is
like oh my god your song like really
helped me
it like really changed my insides in a
way that was really helpful
and your books have done that for me so
it's such a sweet thing to be able to
talk to you
thank you yes sir this is really magical
thank you very very much
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other
you